[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and I hate to be the
bearer of bad news especially since I'm
a huge fan of seven deadly sins myself
but despite reports that seven deadly
sins season two is going to air on
Netflix on February 17th that did not
happen
the only thing currently available on
Netflix in terms of new material for
seven deadly sins is the four episode
OVA called signs of a holy war which
aired back in August in Japan so yeah
even though Netflix specifically
announced season 2 and even though many
mainstream media outlets pick that up
and reported it it turns out that no
season 2 is not yet out and we knew that
this would happen all along and the
reason that we suspected that there
would be no season 2 available yet is
that we've been checking the official
Japanese website for seven deadly sins
on a regular basis and there has been
nothing at all there about a season two
the only news that we've been getting
has been about the OVA and its official
release on DVD and blu-ray later on this
year and think about it guys it would
just make no sense for the official
Japanese website not to announce a
season two if it existed it would make
no sense for them not to hype it up so
they can sell as much merchandise as
possible the second reason why we knew
that there would be no season two is
that the Netflix trailer for season two
did not include any new material it only
included material from the sands of holy
war OVA
which as I already said aired back last
summer in Japan and to be honest the
only people that should be blamed here
are the people and Netflix I myself am a
Netflix user I'm a customer
but I think what they did in this case
is really scummy they clearly announced
that seven deadly sins season two would
be coming out on February 17th and
naturally a bunch of media outlets
picked this up and reported it on top of
that they created a season 2 trailer
which did not include any clips from
season 2 only old material from the OVA
now I don't know about you guys but to
me this sounds like false advertising
either they hired someone to do their
marketing who doesn't know that a full
season of anime cannot be only four
episodes or they deliberately mislead
people announced
- when they knew it wouldn't come just
to get more customers to get Netflix
memberships which would be like I said
really scummy so I don't know this was
pretty shocking to me we kept getting
comments on our other 7 Deadly Sins
video by people saying dude it's coming
out February 17th it's official Netflix
announced it but whenever we try to
double check that information when we
looked at the evidence we just couldn't
see any evidence that a season 2 even
existed so what do you guys think about
this whole situation
why did Netflix do this are you upset
let me know down in the comments also be
sure to subscribe and click that
notification bell for all the latest
news about seven deadly sins season 2
the real season 2 we're going to stay on
top of this we're gonna be looking at
the official website and we're gonna let
you know as soon as we know more and you
can check out our previous seventh at
least sin season 2 video where we talk
about all the most important things that
happen in the signs of a holy war ova
and where we also talk about what is
going to happen or what might happen in
season 2 so that's it for this quick
video stay tuned for more seven that
these sends news and Theory videos and
if you want to chat about all this stuff
in greater detail you can join our
discord server the link is in the
description and until next time see ya
space Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]